hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to DP oh now we're
gonna explore the other game mode that
is available then in my opinion is
incredibly fun and I'm gonna try to go a
completely different route than I've
gone before which is whoa hey how's it
going so in this one this is called D
this is called team deathmatch I can't
even talk today but I'm trying to figure
things out but in this one obviously as
is evident in KC obviously wasn't Evan -
oh my god there are two teams on the map
and so these two teams are fighting for
control now the one thing that I don't
like about team deathmatch is that all
the bullets are the same color are they
wait no that that doesn't seem right
so in team deathmatch I don't know why I
thought this but I thought all the
bullets were all the same color but in
this time they're of a different color
so you got your reds in your blues and
they're all fighting against each other
so in this one it is actually a pretty
decent one there's one guy on the blue
team that seems to be pretty high up on
the leaderboards but as far as we know
it's fairly split even which doesn't
happen a lot in team deathmatch so my
objective is to get to number one with
the leaderboard as usual like I usually
do but this time I'm gonna be doing it
probably as some sort of a sniper
because I believe that I'll be able to
do better now the thing about this one
what what makes this one interesting is
that there's like bases that you can
hide in and so a lot of players do they
they just high end up hiding in their
base and they don't actually go out very
much and that's a coward's way out whoa
hey hey big guy how you doing over there
so I'm gonna go sniper this time because
I don't usually do that but sniper is a
little bit better because it allows you
to see more of the battlefield than what
you usually see in the other play styles
which is very advantageous when you're
trying to and and the bullets go way
farther oh my god dude stop with your
triple cannons oh I almost hatch buddy
what's wrong what's wrong you want to
run away from the market uh oh you died
I don't know how he died I bumped up
against an object and died what a loser
hey it's lie oh geez who's that over
there
who's that over there someone crossed
over enemy lines shouldn't be where you
oh geez no god stop taking up all the
pool that's not good
whoa someone's on whoa geez I forgot how
far out I went not saying I'm just a
little baby Marco fart I can't possibly
handle all of the death and destruction
I believe I believe I believe I believe
okay I'm getting up there I'm level 22
now so pretty soon I'll be able to do
what I need to do I'm gonna get more
reload speed because goddammit I need
more bullets you more bullets pumped out
of everywhere because I gotta get some
of these things killed or else I'm never
gonna get in
goddamn points spent for protection I
don't need your protection I go in raw
hello oh god I don't know what does that
it's like the force there's a type of um
there's a type of tank that actually has
like little ai-controlled triangles
that'll go out and [ __ ] up everyone
else's [ __ ] and I don't have those I
don't know how to get those and also in
the middle oh it looks like the leader
got killed
yeah I didn't get it I ever did
so saber is pretty basic okay so I could
be the assassin or the hunter I don't
know what the hunter is but I think the
overseer is the thing that does the
ships I don't know what the hunter does
though I'm gonna try it I've never done
it before
Oh what what is that it's like a shotgun
blast well there's a helpful at all I
guess actually this could definitely
catch people off-guard I bet cuz they
wouldn't see it coming it's kind of got
a spray pattern like a big one and a
small one hello
looks like Reds kind of taking over the
whole place here geez ups so many rats
well I wanted a fair fight I actually
wanted to i'll pail battle but it
doesn't look like I'm gonna get that who
hello is this enemies and oh me oh my
let's get upgraded
who's there who's there huh [ __ ]
that doesn't seem good someone's over
there I don't know I wasn't going for
you little guy I was going for the big
guy wherever he is I am kind of close to
enemy territory here I don't know if
this is exactly where I want to be quick
wink I will kill you will kill the
market fire will kill more the blue team
leader is over there somewhere he's
probably hiding out in the base because
it seems to be pretty much stopped up
over here anyway
whoa whoa whoa that guy got destroyed oh
my god I just saw my teammate get
annihilated and I did nothing
yeah well what am I gonna do what could
I do yep a barrage Iggy Pablo be a
brewski
huh brewski how proof how proof whoa I
got a hit on that guy whoa jeez whoa
geez oh gosh I shouldn't be this far
deep in enemy territory huh I gotta get
back to the middle because that's where
I'm gonna get the most of my points
because this is just competition and
it's gonna be a long climb to the top
good jeez but I I can see the advantage
of this thing already because my bullet
speed is so high that it's easy for me
to sneak up on people and and nab them
before they able to get away and the
damage is ridiculous so all good
features yeah but I'm not even on the
leaderboard yet I'm an embarrassment to
everybody that ever played this game I
can do better I can always do better I
know I can do better
I've done better before I've dominated
the leaderboards arguably is something
other than this I've kind of handicap
myself as far as getting points goes
unless I can kill other people which i
think is my only want in life so I shall
do exactly that and if I can't succeed
in that then I'm not worthy of even
being here I'm not worthy of being alive
ah whoa geez oh geez oh gosh bull Gersh
someone's someone's doing a thing
did I kill them all son the bullet
stopped whoo hey poink ha
okay so now that's good there's like an
announcement when you actually kill
somebody which is awfully handy I like
it that thank you for the shield Axl
you're definitely helping me out here I
don't think you can shoot anything into
their spawn who killed that guy I killed
him dead oh my god thanks for the
support everybody Oh Axl Axl was in
trouble there
holy [ __ ] those things hurt oh my god
those things hurt ah stop I'm busy oh I
killed somebody
I accidentally but I killed somebody big
I don't even know how whoa geez I got
points out of that one whoo I got off to
level 45 already I'm on the leaderboard
baby I don't know who I killed
lol I guess he must have been big whoa
LMFAO LMFAO
I think those must be like these must be
like automated things that just fire out
of the blue base to try to hone in on
the red base maybe I have no idea
hard to say Rojo woah woah woah woah
woah sprang someone sprang for someone
spraying way too much oh jeez I can't
handle spray of this magnitude I will
admit Hunter's not my favorite thing
it's it doesn't seem to be as powerful
as something could be I mean it's pretty
good if I just keep shooting in a
certain direction but it's just based on
random chance I don't know if I'm gonna
get the kills that I want to get also
people have mentioned that I can just
hold down the button and oh I killed
Carson yeah oh sorry killed em and mgesa
jizz what killed mt savage crow I'm
killing up a storm of weaklings who
doesn't matter if they can't pull up a
fight all right let's see if Axl's gonna
give me the support I need whoop killed
asdf again that guy keeps running into
death over and over again go Axl go go
Axl go I got your back from way over
here
Oh Axl got killed never mind Axl
I don't got your back I got loll again
yeah I killed TT I don't know who TT was
but probably an easy target LMFAO you
want to come back here I want to play I
want to play I'm gonna play oh I killed
[ __ ] wibbled whoo I killed a nun named
tank
I feel bad kind of maybe a little bit
not really yes combine our forces this
is how we do it hopefully I don't know
if it's going to work but this is how
some people do it
Oh killed a nun named tank I'm on the
leaderboard baby yeah and with that my
power grows my power grows infinitely
unlimitedly see this is what I like
about the game mode because you can push
with your teammates but you can try to
go on your own if you're like a sniper
glass like me but you know but for the
most part you like it really is kind of
a rallying cry when you're just all
together as one and able to just push
the enemy back and right now it's kind
of one-sided when I started the game it
was it was fairly even but now it's
gotten a little bit embarrassing like
before the enemy had one of the biggest
players on the board and probably when
he died one of our guys got really big
so that's unfold
that was probably gonna be death if I
didn't even gone a little bit for it I
would have been caught by all three
which is not good I want it I want it I
want it I want it [ __ ] this is more
satisfying to click randomly to click
spastically forever and ever
okay I'm number seven on the leaderboard
six on my team LMFAO
looks like you died at some point I
almost had you I killed a nun named tank
though keep feeling bad about that uh I
feel like these unnamed tanks are just
new guys that are just starting out and
they have nothing left I could kill you
I could kill you I just choose not to
I said definitely choose two we're just
gonna see where you pop up if you go
north or south oh it looks like I may
have some controversy up here does
anybody want to fight the mark of Furth
I'm number five baby number five some
some unfortunate son of a [ __ ] is gonna
cover 12th that guy some other
unfortunate son of a [ __ ] is gonna come
across my bullets and then die in a
horrible blazing fiery death of death
miss who's down here mg Cody mg Cody
dunzo who else is down here Bob
i'ma get you Bob mg cool dead the hunter
steals all kills the hunter claims all
credit are you going ricardo well that's
where you're going away from him oh [ __ ]
if that guy will clear that guy clear
that I said clear that guy Jesus yeah
which oh [ __ ] me what the [ __ ] oh come
on
Oh what even was that what the [ __ ] just
happened oh god damn it what the [ __ ]
happened
what oh god damn it somehow I googled
dee dee dee dee dee dee god damn those
in the middle of a goddamn game happen
how did I Google did - did Dee I killed
him so long ago what the [ __ ] was that
what it turns just eternal into third at
it
dared intend it to do thirty fifty
little to do to do turn it'll do dare
that it did a little let the deal better
than it did it doll [ __ ] all right
whatever
god damn it I'm not gonna be idaite I
can't do it back again okay so I guess
that's the premature end o this episode
of DPO even though I've been playing for
like thirty minutes but still that's not
fair
what the [ __ ] anyway
all right that's team deathmatch mode
team deathmatch mode is fun in my
opinion but there's another game mode
called domination that I've never played
before so I have no idea if it's good or
not but I hear it's the only one that
has a win condition so team deathmatch
might be team versus team but there's no
way to win for your team but in
domination supposedly there is so we
will explore that in the next episode of
DPO thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
you want to command me bread you're
looking up to the bee's knees oh you
wanna hug you want a hug lady all right
too bad all I have is death